sensationelle Entwicklung wir alle
müssen unser Bild von Olaf Scholz völlig
neu denken von wegen farbloser Bürokrat
der Kanzler macht plötzlich die Ansagen
der drückt knallhart deutsche Interessen
durch er ist quasi ja der Alpha Babo der
EU ja und klar das gefällt nicht jedem
unsere Ex Frankreich zum Beispiel ist
menschliche enttäuscht
die Liebe erkaltet jetzt haben die
beleidigten Franzosen sogar die
gemeinsame Kabinettsklausur platzen
lassen Wahnsinn und Monsieur macrons
Körpersprache gegenüber Olaf Scholz
spricht Bände hier begrüßt der kumpelig
den Spanier wollen dass die als Matthias
wer was du noch mal und dann aber ich
lass dich abschlabbern wenn ich nicht
schon eine ältere Frau zu Hause hätte
so warum der deutsch-französische beef
bzw loboess weil der Olaf seinen
doppelwimmst vorher nicht mit Paris
besprochen hat die erwarten dass man
sowas vorher mit Ihnen bespricht warum
noch weil Deutschland zu Hause die
gaspreisbremse will für Europa aber
ausdrücklich nicht
weil wir im Sommer als Deutschland Gas
gekauft haben zu Preisen die sich andere
EU-Staaten nicht leisten können was
wiederum den Gaspreis für alle
hochgetrieben hat und mal ganz abgesehen
davon dass die Eulen Franzosen ja selber
Deckeln kann man macrons Frust schon
nachvollziehen ich stehe hier seit über
fünf Jahren und mache Vorschläge um
Fortschritte zu erzielen und die Einheit
zu bewahren seit fünf Jahren stehst du
da
dann geh doch mal rein
ach so warte mal das geht noch weiter es
ist nicht gut wenn sich ein Land
isoliert
was meint er denn bestimmt die Ungarn
oder Deutschland ist ja eine
Unverschämtheit Deutschland isoliert
sich also das stimmt hundertprozentig
aber man darf natürlich nicht laut sagen
wir Deutschen denken jetzt auch mal an
uns das muss doch erlaubt sein es muss
doch möglich sein ja kann ich immer nur
an andere denken was stimmt wir haben
zum Beispiel weit weniger Gas gespart
als zum Beispiel Schweden oder als die
Niederlande und gleichzeitig dafür
gesorgt dass die Europäische Union bald
eine sogenannte sos-verordnung
durchsetzt die alle Mitgliedstaaten
verpflichtet einander also uns im
Notfall mit Gas auszuhelfen sprechen wir
es mal offen aus wir halten uns für
vorzeige Europäer aber eigentlich sind
wir wie so ein arschloch-tourist an
Buffet dem völlig wurmpel ist auf andere
auch noch was abkriegen das ist nämlich
durch ich bin Deutschland ja das müssen
wir leider so machen denn Deutschland
hat ein riesigen Energie
und wenn wir dann unsere Portion
verfuttert haben dann sollen uns
gefälligst nie was abgeben die sparsam
leben als wir
isst du das noch
ich mag uns trotzdem
okay wir haben unsere Energieversorgung
nie diversifiziert gegen alle Warnung
aber deswegen muss man uns ja trotzdem
helfen in der Not finde ich dank
deutschen Drucks kriegt Europa jetzt
erstmal nur einen dynamischen
gaspreisdecke also übersetzt gar keinen
oder was wurde konkret beschlossen
wir haben einen großen Fortschritt
gestern erreicht aber natürlich auf
dieser Ebene kein konkrete also kein
konkretationsreich gerade erreichen
können wo man sagen kann das ist jetzt
klar was
was ist denn bitte konkretionsgrad
klingt so eine Stadt in Russland
kongressionskraft aber merken Sie was er
macht merken Sie was Scholz macht das
ist ich erinnere mich das wie im
mündlichen Abi wenn man das Buch nicht
gelesen hat und einfach weiter labert
genau so
sicher sicher ob so ein EU-weiter Deckel
Sinn macht darüber kann man durchaus
trefflich streiten definitiv Grund
falsches aber kritische Infrastruktur an
die Chinesen zu verhökern und auch da
setzt sich King Olaf über alle Warnungen
hinweg Stichwort Hamburger Hafen
bestimmt gelesen der chinesische
Staatskonzern Costco kriegt jetzt
immerhin noch
24,9% von einem Hamburger Hafenterminal
und das obwohl sechs Bundesministerien
explizit dagegen sind der Bundeskanzler
wollte unbedingt diesen Deal mit China
und hat sich durchgesetzt mehrere
Bundesministerien haben gesagt nein doch
sie wurden vom Kanzler überstimmt der
Bundeskanzler fand es doch der
Bundeskanzler drückt die Entscheidung
durch sein Kabinett bei Kanzler Scholz
ist so will durchgedrückt durchgesetzt
durchgesetzt Alleingang man fragt sich
so ein bisschen warum macht Olaf Scholz
das tja da fragen Sie mich was
ja und zwar absichtlich fragen wir dich
das
warum lernen wir nicht aus unseren
Fehlern natürlich vergrößert der
cosco-deal die Abhängigkeit von China
wahrscheinlich ist das schon Olafs
Gastgeschenk für seinen pekingbesuch
nächste Woche es steht ja nächste Woche
an das ist wahrscheinlich schon
kleines Mitbringsel jetzt ist es ja so
chinesische Firmen sind schon an über
einem Dutzend europäischer Häfen
beteiligt will sagen die Folgen einer
langfristigen Strategie während sich
EU-Staaten gegeneinander ausspielen
lassen warum drückt der Kanzler das mit
aller Macht durch und noch wichtiger
warum arbeitet er nebenbei als
Pressesprecher vom Hamburger Hafen weil
ich glaube dass jemand der dort nicht
aufgewachsen ist keine Idee von der
Größe des Hafens hat und Dimensionen
sich besser einschätzen lassen was ist
ein Teil und was ist das Ganze wenn man
das in seinem Leben schon mal gesehen
hat am besten aus einem Hubschrauber da
sind einige sehr beeindruckend ja
natürlich
natürlich du du so ein Hafen von oben
sieht völlig anders aus als ein Hafen
von unten ja mittlerweile braucht man
einen Hubschrauber um das Ego von Olaf
Scholz in voller Dimension zu erfassen
ja ein Kanzler Machtwort jagt hier das
nächste vor allem der arme Robert Habeck
wird quasi wöchentlich typiert vom
Kanzler so schlimm ist das traurig ist
das jetzt der neue scholzstil in der
Bundesregierung hier anonyme Informanten
packen aus sobald die kabinettstürze nur
rum einmal habe ich mich laut genug über
einen Witz von ihm gelacht da hat er
mich vor allem in den Schwitzkasten
genommen und fiesen Nippel Dreher
gemacht er darf nie erfahren dass ich
mit ihm rede kann ich mich darauf
verlassen ich habe Angst
er zwingt mich ständig neue Schulden zu
machen es ist so ein niedrigen aber ich
sage wo soll denn das ganze Geld
herkommen Olaf schreit er mich an dein
Problem geh doch auf den Strich du Loser
also ich hier genug gemütlich über den
Mann charismatisch gut aussehen voll
nett und wer was anderes sagt kriegt das
Maul
[Applaus]
ein Klima der Angst
macht Worte geben sich die Klinke in die
Hand deprimierend aber wahr viele
Koalitionen bleiben nur zusammen weil
sie Angst haben keine neuen Partner mehr
zu finden selbst Frank Walter Steinmeier
warnt diese Woche vor zu viel
Abhängigkeit von China also der Mann der
uns zu viel Abhängigkeit von Russland
mit eingebrockt hat der Bundespräsident
der heute Vormittag endlich seine große
Wir-Gefühl energiekrisen durchhalte Rede
gehalten hat
war bestimmt gut ich habe sie leider
verpasst ja auf die Rede konnte man
warten oder sich mal selbst ans Deutsche
Volk wenden wie unser
heute-show-präsident Frank Walter
Wischmeyer lebe Miteigentümer der
Schrottimmobilie Deutschland soll
männlich werde ich sauer auf euch
verwöhntes packen hört endlich mit dem
Gejammer auf ihr habt uns zu sehr von
Russland abhängig gemacht na und sonst
wollte uns halt keine Erdgas für einen
halben Weltmarktpreis liefern was hätten
wir denn machen sollen ja wir haben
Putin auch die Gasspeicher verkauft und
Consuela Schwesig an eine russische
Zeitarbeitsfirma vermittelt wir brauchen
den Stoff weil ihr stumpft werden jeden
Tag duschen wollt
dauernd fliegt er nach Kroatien und
fressen Schweinehack wie eine
streifenhyäne ihr habt doch mit dem
billigen Gas euer Wohnzimmer auf
Körpertemperatur geheizt um nackig
unterschiedsfernsehen zu glotzen perfekt
das geht jetzt nicht mehr und noch ein
Atom meiner wird die Ampel nicht
hochfahren nur damit ihr euren faltigen
Arsch auch im Winter in den Garten
Whirlpool Stippen könnt habt ihr
wirklich gedacht Deutschland kann sich
von guten Vorsätzen ernähren jawohl lebt
er eigentlich ja ich weiß im Einklang
mit der Schöpfung ich nenne das Blackout
oder für nicht Lateiner zappenduster
warum wohl kriegt denn Olaf Scholz
nächste Woche auf dem Zahnfleisch ins
Reich der Mitte um sich zu entschuldigen
weil es nicht geschafft hat das cosco
den kompletten Hamburger Hafen
sandreeperbahn bekommen hat wenn wir
richtig viel Glück haben kauft uns
skiganking vielleicht auch noch die
Deutsche Bahn ab und da höre ich die
bärbock direkt wiederholen wir dürfen
nicht unsere Infrastrukturen ein
autoritäres System verkaufen ja welche
Infrastruktur bitte wir können doch froh
sein über jeden der uns was abnimmt von
der kaputten Museumstechnik
das eine kann ich euch aber versprechen
Freunde so oder so geht ihr demnächst
der Waschlappen in den streckbetrieb und
nicht nur der mit dem ihr euch im
Schritt rumfreudelt sondern einer der
ist aufweckt die Party ist vorbei
kein Deutscher unter 35 wird jemals eine
Doppelgarage besitzen und unsere
wund-pötherigen Enkel werden das
dreilagige nur noch aus Erzählung ihrer
Großeltern kennen da helfen wieder
doppelwumms noch gasdeckel seid froh
wenn ihr nicht den von eurem Sarg von
innen zu machen müsst
in diesem Sinne Schluss mit jaulen
Schlüpfer die Kämmer Reisen und nur noch
eine Produktinformation diese Rede wurde
ermöglicht durch ein Notstromaggregat
made in China nehau und gute Nacht
[Applaus]
so meine Damen und Herren jetzt aber mal
was heiteres Großbritannien ja
das reicht schon das Wort Großbritannien
das Mutterland der Comedy ist offiziell
nur noch Comedy mit Richi sunak kriegen
die Briten ihren dritten Premierminister
in nur zwei Monaten was für ein
Verschleiß nach List Trust isunak
außerdem der zweite in Folge der ohne
Parlamentswahl ins ankommt was muss ich
sonst noch wissen über den mit nur 42
Jahren ist er der jüngste
Premierminister der letzten zwei
Jahrhunderte 2020 wurde er zum heißesten
Abgeordneten im Parlament gewählt
ja also entschuldigung aber direkt neben
Boris Johnson
sehe sogar ich heiß aus meine Damen und
Herren keine Kunst
ist das jetzt mitleidsablauf oder was
so außerdem Freunde ist mir das viel zu
oberflächlich ne der neue ist ja nicht
nur wahnsinnig hot sondern auch
wahnsinnig Reich ich ja der ehemalige
Goldman Sachs Baker besitzt zusammen mit
seiner Frau der Tochter eines indischen
Milliardärs geschätzte 860 Millionen
Euro sonak hat also doppelt so viel Geld
auf dem Konto wie König Charles und der
hat ähnlich wenig dafür geleistet aber
wie schafft es so einer den Bezug zum
einfachen Volk zu behalten
gut ja da waren noch sehr jung in dem
Alter hatte ich selbst auch noch keinen
Chauffeur und keine Putzfrau aber es ist
schon ulkig nicht wenige Briten haben
auch aus rassistischen Motiven für den
brexit gestimmt und kriegen jetzt den
ersten indisch stämmigen Premierminister
das beweist es gibt doch einen Gott und
der ist hin du meine Damen und Herren
gesehen davon kann diese Insel sicher
nur verbessern nach List Trust oh Gott
List Trust nach gerade mal 45 Tagen im
Amt oder sie nach Hause geschickt
gnadenlos weggeschickt aber im
Grunde im Grunde viel zu spät ihre
idiotische Idee Steuern für Reiche zu
senken ohne jede Gegenfinanzierung hat
das Land noch weiter Richtung Abgrund
geschubst und nicht nur das es war schon
kein gutes oben dass die Queen List
Trust zur Premierministerin ernannt
hatte und zwei Tage später starb
gut
den Zusammenhang sehe ich jetzt nicht
direkt
aber trotzdem guter Hinweis es war Mord
meine Damen und Herren
ich behaupte List Trust weil die
gerechte Strafe für den brexit ja brexit
dann kriegt man halt PolitikerInnen die
nur noch unhaltbare Versprechungen
machen Fakten ignorieren oder über Käse
reden
das ist ein disgrade
absolute Schande Engländer ja ihr
produziert schon sehr viele sortenkäse
aber man kann ja keiner davon essen
wirklich mit List Trust ist eine Ära zu
Ende gegangen präzise gesagt eine
sechswöchige Ära und es ist irgendwie
schade dass bald keiner mehr ihren Namen
kennt denn es gibt so viele
faszinierende Fakten über List Trust
wussten sie List Trust war die erste
Premierministerin seit Churchill die
zwei Königinnen erlebt hat wahnsinnig
habe einfach geändert haben sie es
gemerkt sechs Wochen klingt wenig aber
sie war die am längsten regierende
Premierministerin seit Maggie Fetscher
und hier der anderen die immer so
schlimm getanzt hat fakt ist vor sechs
Wochen geborene englische Babys kennen
keine andere Premierministerin als List
Truck und jetzt wo sie weg ist kämpft
niemand mehr für englischen Käse Elton
John hat schon die passende Ballade
geschrieben
goodbye britis
we have of the charts YouTube
[Musik]
ja wirklich
Gänsehaut es ist für mich unglaublich
schwer zu sagen wer peinlicher war im
Nachhinein List Trust oder vielleicht
doch ihr Vorgänger Boris Johnson es ist
Augenhöhe ich finde es ist ein Kopf an
Kopf Rennen was mir besonders gefallen
hat dass die notorische Skandalnudel
Boris nach Frau Trust Rücktritt sofort
sein Karibikurlaub abbricht um nach
London zu fliegen nur um dort zu
erfahren dass sie gar keiner gerufen hat
wunderbar wunderbar so aber wie geht's
weiter auf der comedy-insel Bescheid mal
live zu unserem Korrespondenten
Christian Ehring live vor Downing Street
10 Christian was wird sich denn jetzt
ändern unter Premierminister sunak oh oh
Oliver da hängen sie der Entwicklung
aber um mehrere Minuten hinterher Richie
sunack ist natürlich längst
zurückgetreten das Umzugsunternehmen
trägt gerade seine persönlichen Sachen
raus nee nee nee nee nee Moment Moment
nein die ist von Boris Johnson die
bleibt
wissen viele nicht mehr aber die Puppe
war tatsächlich Familienministerin im
letzten Kabinett Johnson es geht so
schnell hier du kommst einfach nicht
hinterher ja ich komme auch nicht mehr
hinter warum ist denn der zounak jetzt
schon wieder zurückgetreten keine Ahnung
ich glaube seine Frau ist steinreich hat
eine Firma hat wohl aber in England
praktisch nie Steuern gezahlt vielleicht
deshalb wer weiß doch noch warum hier
irgendjemand zurück ich frage auch gar
nicht mehr verstehe und wer wird's jetzt
gute Frage ich find mal ein die
Ratingagenturen haben Großbritannien
erst auf Ramsch runtergestuft und dann
auf Boris Becker
wer will den Job freiwillig machen die
haben in ihrer Verzweiflung schon die
Bude hier bei Airbnb reingestellt kann
man übers Wochenende günstig mieten muss
dann aber auch die zwei Tage lang
Premierminister sein um Gottes Willen
ich denke gar nicht dran ah hier wie
wäre es denn mit den winds ich finde
wenn man sich schon so eine
Königsfamilie hält können die doch auch
mal regieren fürs ganze Geld oder können
die nur Inzucht das ist die Frage König
Charles hat tatsächlich kurz drüber
nachgedacht aber dann haben ihm seine
Berater gesagt dass man als Premiere
recht arbeiten muss das Wort kannte er
nicht und hat abgesagt der einzige
Winzer der es eventuell machen würde ist
der junge Prinz Louis und der bringt ja
eigentlich alles mit schauen Sie mal er
ist arrogant er ist aggressiv und er ist
komplett beratungsresistent kurz gesagt
ein echter vorzeiger Engländer aber
leider ist es wohl so seine Mutter
besteht darauf dass er erstmal den
Kindergarten zu Ende macht ciao wirklich
ich höre gerade sensationelle breaking
news kommissarisch teilen sich den Job
des Premierministers ab sofort die
beiden Corgis der Verstorbenen Queen
weil sie Zeit haben die geben mir gleich
ihre erste Pressekonferenz ja also ich
weiß nicht wie es Ihnen geht Oliver aber
ich finde das sind die besten
Premierminister die Großbritannien diese
Woche hatte finde ich auch für England
reichts Christian
[Applaus]
hallo die Leute ich wollte euch nur um
ein kleines Abo bitten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
na los
na los du scheiß Pferd hey